because at the end of the day whatever
path and life they choose once they come
out of our school system they are going
to be citizens of this Republic and I
think we owe it to not just ourselves
and our kids future but people that have
sacrificed in the past uh that they go
into that duty of citizenship with a
sense of what America means and the
principles that we were founded on they
need an adequate foundation so we're
doing that in the State of Florida and I
think it's going to make a big
difference as these kids get older we've
also drawn A Line in the Sand to say
it's not appropriate for a school
teacher to be asking a second grader if
they want to change their gender or
telling them that their gender is a
choice that is wrong and we put a stop
to that in the State of Florida now when
we did that the parents throughout
Florida were ecstatic and it didn't
matter if you were a Republican or a
Democrat they parents want the kids
focused on school work on the basics
they don't want the ideology put in and
so they were thankful now the left
didn't like it the media didn't like it
and there was happened to be one company
that you may have heard of in Central
Florida that didn't like it and tried to
stop at Disney but at the end of the day
uh we run the State of Florida we don't
subcontract out our leadership to a woke
company in in Burbank California and
even though people said that they would
end up being able to defeat our parents
rights legislation we stood our ground
and we got it done we beat them on that
we also insured that um you know to have
one Corporation
enjoy what they had in Florida they
actually had their own government that
they controlled for 60 years and this
was something that was totally
unjustifiable but they were just so
politically powerful that they were able
to keep this going well given that
they've embraced this troubling Trend in
society to sexualize young people we
felt that that Arrangement could not
work anymore in the State of Florida and
so we followed up uh and we took action
and signed legislation to end Disney
self-governing status in the State of
Florida they are living under the same
laws as everybody else and they are
paying
and that's how it should have always
been and I know you have Republicans
that are out there criticizing me and
taking the side of Disney uh first of
all I don't think you should be for
corporate welfare but that aside uh we
stand for the protection of our children
we will do battle with anybody that
seeks to Rob them of their innocence and
on those principles there will not be
any compromise
[Applause]
thank you
so I think that Florida I think he chose
a couple things one you know shows this
stuff can be done because I came in as
governor in 2018 winning by 32 000 votes
out of more than eight million votes
cast I was actually advised find your
time keep your head down Don't Rock the
Boat the state's so evenly balanced
politically you don't want to upset the
apple cart and then maybe you wouldn't
be able to get reelected and I
understand why they said that but with
all due respect I rejected that advice
we went in on day one uh we were very
bold we were very ambitious fast forward
four years later November of 2022 we
don't win by 32 000 votes we win by over
1.5 million votes the largest Chicago
marketing area history in Florida
highest percentage of voter Republican
governor candidate has ever gotten and
it wasn't just uh you know winning and
winning big but we were winning rural
areas with massive margin all the
Suburban areas and even urban areas like
Miami-Dade County 2.8 million people
Hillary Clinton won the county by 30
points in 2016 presidential election we
were able to not only win the county we
wanted by double digits we were winning
places that Republicans haven't won in
an awful long time including winning
independent voters by 18 percentage
points and winning more than 60 percent
of Hispanic voters and so that is what
you call
bringing people to your platform and
attracting voters we also earn super
majorities in the Florida legislature we
earned we had picked up four Republican
members of the U.S House of
Representatives probably would have the
majority if we didn't do that and we
elected 29 conservative schools members
across the State of Florida because look
at the end date if you're leading the
ticket you're the leader it's not just
about you okay you have to be looking
out for these other offices you need a
rising tide to lift all boats and so we
work very hard to help everybody get in
and the net result is today in Florida
for the first time since the era of the
Civil War there's not one single
solitary Democrat elected to Statewide
office
foreign
Florida shows is that and I think even
my my most significant political
adversaries down there would acknowledge
when when the governor says he's going
to do something he hasn't just make idle
promises he is going to do it so you can
take that to the bank and you can know
that what I'm saying what I'm going to
do as president I'm going to follow
through on all of this I am not just
saying things to get elected I'm only
going to say it if I mean it and so I
pledge as president to be an energetic
executive who will go on offense who
will take on the big issues head on is
not going to shy away from a fight
because the media doesn't like it or the
left doesn't like it we are going to
reverse Biden's disastrous economic
policies
we're going to establish fiscal
responsibility we're going to make sure
the focus of our economy is not on the
big Corporation but on the small
businesses that power American
communities from coast to coast and we
are not going to let China continue to
eat our lunch we need to make more
things in the United States we cannot
rely on them
all these important materials and goods
anymore
I will as somebody as a republican who's
watched this issue for a long time for
years and years Republicans have been
talking about securing the southern
border and yet here we are I will be the
president that finally brings this issue
to a conclusion we are going to shut the
border down we are going to build the
border wall
migration we are going to hold a Mexican
drug cartels accountable for the Carnage
they have been click it from this
country
we will also Usher in a reckoning for
the federal government's disastrous
policies regarding the covid-19 pandemic
vouchy policies were destructive balji's
policies were wrong we desperately need
accountability for those failures so
that we can ensure this never happens in
our country ever again
[Applause]
because we recognize that the woke mind
virus represents a war on the truth we
pledge to wage a war on the woe we will
fight the woke in the schools we will
fight the woke and the businesses we
will fight the woke in the halls of
Congress we will never ever surrender to
the woke mob we will leave woke ideology
in the Dustbin of History where it
belongs
[Applause]
and on day one as commander-in-chief we
will restore Integrity to our military
all the politicization is gone on day
one we're gonna clean house and make
sure we have the military people can be
proud of and a military that's capable
of defending our country because China
is eating our lunch in this realm as
well when they see the Navy doing drag
queen for recruiting China is laughing
at us and they're building their
military and they have Ambitions and we
need to make sure we can check China
because I don't want the 21st century to
be the Chinese Century I want it to be
the American Century
we will also work on day one to
reconstitutionalize the government and
that means bringing this administrative
state to heal once and for all we have a
country that has allowed a massive
amount of power to accumulate in
Washington D.C and these agencies that
are not held constitutionally
accountable by either the elected
president or the Congress itself yes it
is a quote deep State and we need to
bring it to heal but you only do that by
going in on day one being willing to do
things like for example with me you know
day one you'll have a new FBI director
everything
you gotta go in you've got to be able to
be willing to use your article to
Authority you've got to be disciplined
you've got to be focused you got to
understand that this is going to be a
battle uh that's going to go on uh and
you got to be willing to fight that and
I will be willing to do it and
understand when people say that they're
gonna slay the Deep state in a day or
six months
um I'm sorry this is something that only
a two-term president is going to be able
to bring intuition
because the bureaucrats will just wait
you out if you're a Linked UP president
they'll wait you out as soon as you're
gone they'll change it they'll go back
to no so you know anyone that says that
they can uh slay the Deep state in six
months should be asked why didn't you do
that when you had four years to try to
do that
[Applause]
so we will make sure that this
government uh gets put back under
constitutional accountability and part
of the right way you have to do that is
to understand and have some humility the
president is yes the decider you're
going to be responsible for the big
decisions and the policy but you cannot
do it alone you need a Cadre of people
who are going to descend on Washington
uh who are not from Washington uh but
are coming with you because they share
the mission and they're going to put the
mission before any Personal Agenda that
they may have you can't just recycle
everybody from DC and expect to get a
different result so we're going to be
asking Americans from all across the
country you know if you're qualified to
serve in the administration we want you
to pick up your family maybe move to D.C
for two four six eight years and help us
you know DC DC has imposed the
bureaucracy in DC has imposed its will
on us for far too long it's about time
we impose our will on it and that's
exactly what we're going to do
and we're going to be doing a lot more
stuff and I look forward we're going to
be in New Hampshire a lot you're going
to see me all the time and we're going
to talk about a whole host of other
policies and initiatives and I'll lay
out other things that we'll do and uh
and it's going to be great stuff but
here's the deal none of that matters if
you don't win there's no substitute for
victory and we need to shape this
culture of losing that's infected our
party in recent years I look at this
debt deal and as bad as it was you know
we had won the Senate races we were
supposed to win we have 55 Republican
Senators right now maybe we actually
could have gotten a good deal you know
if that were the case and so I want uh
under people to understand we're not
getting a mulligan with this 2024
election we've got to get it right and
I'll be the guy to do that because the
Democrats are playing for keys if
they're able to sweep this election in
24 White House Senate and House they are
going to pack the the U.S Supreme Court
they are going to make Washington D.C a
state so they get two more Democrat
Senators for Life they're going to try
to abolish the Electoral College and
they're going to try to eliminate Ballot
or voter ID everywhere in the country
and mandate ballot harvesting everywhere
in the country that's not an agenda
that's addressing the kitchen table
concerns of the average American family
no that's an agenda where one side is
trying to ensconce themselves in power
and if they're able to do that it will
be a generation before we will be able
to recover Ronald Reagan used to say
that freedom is one generation away from
Extinction it's not passed along in the
bloodstream and I used to think that was
a little bit overwrought we're Americans
after all isn't this Freedom just in our
DNA but living through the last four or
five years I've never seen the
incursions on freedom that we've seen
over the last four or five years I
wouldn't have thought it was possible
that a blue State could lock down
churches while allowing liquor stores
instead clubs to operate and yet that's
happened in the United States of America
and so freedom is fragile uh we this is
not something we can take for granted
our founding fathers understood this
they studied when they met in
Philadelphia to frame the Constitution
they studied the found the history of
every Republic in the history of mankind
because they wanted to draw lessons from
those experiences and what they found
was there was really only one thing that
all of those republics had in common and
it was this
every one of them had failed and so they
understood it felt that the United
States of America to answer the question
once and for all can people really
govern themselves can you have a society
based on the idea that our rights come
from God not from the government that we
live under a rule of law not the rule of
individual men or was mankind forever
destined to live under various forms of
despotism and they fully expected this
country would answer that question but
they also understood and Benjamin
Franklin reflected this when he walked
out of the convention he was asked did
you give us a republic or a monarchy Dr
Franklin he said a republic if you can
keep it he understood that you could
have the best Declaration of
Independence in the world you could have
the best constitution in the world these
things do not run on autopilot they
require each generations of Americans to
cultivate the freedom that we've been
deque and so we have responsibilities as
Citizens to get this right we have a
responsibility to carry the torch of
what George Washington called The Sacred
fire of Liberty we have a responsibility
to stand firm for the truth we have a
responsibility to remain Resolute in
defense of our enduring American
principles I believe we have it within
our power to reverse America's Decline
and restore this nation to the greatness
that it deserves and my pledge to you is
this
if you work with me to be nominated as
the Republican candidate for president
then on January and you can set your
clock to January 20th 2025 at High Noon
because on the west side of the Capitol
I will have my left hand on the Bible I
will have my right hand in the air I
will be taking the oath of office as the
47th president to be in the United
States
you will get the job done thank you all
God bless
come on